(upbeat music)
- Alright, y'all, we're back in,
and our next guests make
quite the talented pairing.
She is a gifted actress
and singer who you've seen
in shows like "Victorious"
and MTV's "Eye Candy,"
and films including "A Perfect
Pairing and "The Tutor."
He is an acclaimed songwriter,
producer and pianist.
I actually worked with him
on a couple of my songs on Stronger album.
He's also the man behind
huge hits for Madonna,
John Legend, Beyonce, so many people.
Now performing a cover of
Fergie's "Big Girls Don't Cry"
from his forthcoming album
"Piano Diaries Volume One,"
give it up for Toby Gad
and Victoria Justice,
(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ The smell of your
skin lingers on me now ♪
♪ You're probably on your
flight back to your hometown ♪
♪ I need some shelter ♪
♪ Of my own protection, baby ♪
♪ To be with myself and center ♪
♪ Clarity, peace, serenity ♪
♪ I hope you know ♪
♪ That this has nothing to do with you ♪
♪ It's personal, myself and I ♪
♪ We got some straightening out to do ♪
♪ And I'm gonna miss you ♪
♪ Like a child misses their blanket ♪
♪ But I gotta get a move on with my life ♪
♪ It's time to be a big girl now ♪
♪ And big girls don't cry ♪
♪ Don't cry, don't cry, don't cry ♪
♪ The path that I'm walking ♪
♪ I must go alone ♪
♪ I must take the baby steps ♪
♪ Til I'm full grown ♪
♪ Full grown ♪
♪ But fairy tales don't always ♪
♪ Have a happy ending do they ♪
♪ And I foresee the dark ahead if I stay ♪
♪ I hope you know, I hope you know ♪
♪ That this has nothing to do with you ♪
♪ It's personal, myself and I ♪
♪ We got some straightening out to do ♪
♪ And I'm gonna miss you ♪
♪ Like a child misses their blanket ♪
♪ But I gotta get a move on with my life ♪
♪ It's time to be a big girl now ♪
♪ And big girls don't cry ♪
♪ Like a little school
mate in the school yard ♪
♪ We'll play jax and Uno cards ♪
♪ And I'll be your best friend ♪
♪ And you'll be my Valentine ♪
♪ Yes you can hold my
hand if you want to ♪
♪ 'Cause I wanna hold yours too ♪
♪ We'll be playmates and lovers ♪
♪ And share our secret world ♪
♪ I hope you know, I hope you know ♪
♪ That this has nothing to do with you ♪
♪ It's personal, myself and I ♪
♪ We got some straightening out to do ♪
♪ And I'm gonna miss you ♪
♪ Like a child misses their blanket ♪
♪ But I gotta get a move on with my life ♪
♪ It's time to be a big girl now ♪
♪ And big girls don't cry ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- One more time for Victoria Justice
and Toby Gad, y'all.
"Piano Diaries Volume One features some of
Toby's greatest songs reimagine.
Look for it (indistinct).